what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here with that cyber channel from
YouTube and twitch is that cyber channel
on both those also part of the tgn
squadron over at youtube.com slash user
slash games what was that noise
dreams love that understood hey damn
let's continue or late III reactions
with God of War maybe a warrior trailer
ps4 e3 2017 let's get this on
Kratos yeah I know his name good job I
know his name would listen to you say
his name again
we got a real that boat looks yup well
that's a revealing image see we know
what this trailers are before but can
you imagine being in the conference
event seeing like its new weapon looks
like someone punched his dog he's helped
[Music]
she said I was cursed
you can only because I'm not like you
know at least I know the truth now which
is he killed gods
[Music]
long way from home
[Music]
and here I thought your kind was
supposed to be so enlightened so much
better
oh these realms don't take kindly to
outsiders trust me when they find you
and they will they'll make these
difficult wait here damn right you will
[Music]
- thank God war
[Music]
wow that was something that he plays the
son sometimes will be attacked by old
man creature
to be effective in combat a warrior must
not feel players in available it just
means I lose your heart to the
desperation forgiving no place for a boy
oh sweet yeah oh you go before it
doesn't matter this boy is not your past
where's your son
[Music]
[Music]
right
going on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
exactly he's not gonna kill
be on edge in the end there man I hate
finish
[Music]
oh wow dang dang dang okay
daddy rage has to learn to be a real
daddy yeah there's a lot there's a lot
to dissect in that oh man just a lie
from my understanding this is supposed
to be the serve as a soft furry boot
it's because the last ones were Greek
mythology it's like the eighth one right
yeah its eighth one and this one's
following Norse mythology so really is
still honing on like wolf strange man in
a strange land yeah well I mean like he
basically killed all the gods
yeah like a rectum all and it's kind
like okay cool he's got no war god yeah
it's so interesting it's like okay he's
got nothing else to kill what do we do
to other guys yeah
what's interesting is that like one he
doesn't have his like signature Chains
of Olympus
he's got the ax that's got the ax to a
meringue accent looks like it has some
mythical powers in it it's like smash
like weird [ __ ] starts happening and it
looks like there's some mystical
elements to his axe as well it looks
badass I don't I hope we get like a
little more information about oh he got
that yeah this [ __ ] oh the shield to the
forearm shield that comes out that was
dope that was really cool my biggest
worry for the game is if I have to worry
about the kid I feel like you're going
to worry about the kid until what an
escort mission like that's not what I'm
signing up for like what God of War I'm
signing up to like kill things without
like consequence for my actions maybe
there's an option where you can like
punched a kid sometimes killing if he
gets on your nerves seems like a bad
idea I think that's what we like to call
bad parenting well there are some
moments where all you saw was the kid so
I think sometimes you're gonna play as
Decatur sometimes having as an optional
do scout he's an archer I definitely see
their being apart like with any good
like duo sort of thing you always got
one section where like oh he's knocked
out because someone punched really hard
in the face and now the sons gotta like
go take care of house to get them up or
whatever well yeah and it's gonna give
us a different side to explore to this
guy yeah we're sensitive since the
father's yeah
it looks like he's kind of a tough rough
my nails sort of dad because the kids
like starting off like you don't like me
but he has him around for a reason
because he loves him because it's his
son he has to do right by his kid I
weren't because this is supposed to
serve as a software boot so I'm
wondering how it's gonna evolve is it
gonna turn or something where he dies
and then the kid becomes the main
character when he's an adult I mean
possibly I just what would i hope for
this is that it isn't just gonna be
random angry Kratos yelling because I
mean the first two games that's
basically all he is it's just like some
guys like and like this one is such like
a more calm like almost more mature in
the fact that like he internalizes a lot
of his yeah is pain it'll be interesting
to see when anger comes up and if he if
it's utilized better than just like yeah
well what it seems like he's doing
because he's doing the parenting mentor
role that he's he's trying to also teach
his kid how to channel the rage and
channel the anger for battle right you
know and that's always a cool element
like that movies in general so seeing
that any game would be really cool it
looks like I might get hooked up with
that one shape too I mean he did have
sex with someone to have that kid I'm
wondering it yeah if that was the mother
oh yeah yeah I I mean if anything it's
like the mother's sister or someone that
he will eventually go like I pick you
yeah combat looks dope oh yeah of course
I never got a chance to play ascension
which I think was the latest one usually
it was like a really like wide angle and
you you could like see everything you're
finding this one's very up close and
personal with yeah I kind of dig more
being able to really see what I'm doing
yeah and this looks like a world
exploration yeah but doesn't we're an
open world that's it yeah yeah I mean
that's the thing is like traditionally
it is fairly linear and I wouldn't
expect anything less but it certainly
feels like there's more to the path yeah
which is really cool I'd like that like
I'd like to hope that there's some
branches to like extra goodies yeah
everybody likes a good secret
and explore in Norse mythology maybe
we'll might get Loki and Thor in there
that would be kind of cool to kill Loki
and Thor the MCU version yes this is
literally the setup for Kratos detroit's
all the Norse mythology is now talked
about that what's the world sir
okay so for my basic understanding of
the world serpent I don't know enough
about Norse philosophy and theology and
all that sort of stuff but what I can
gather just from like other fantasy type
things that include him he's basically
just like veers like he's the protector
of the earth he's like this really
almighty powerful thing and so I'm
wondering why is he want to help Kratos
when Kratos is clearly at some point in
time gonna kill him because he has to
kill everything
yeah well you know Loki's staff but I
don't know I think the circuit was
really cool was that rocks are appearing
oh maybe they're on an island it's a
[ __ ] snake
oh god there's so many people who were
like oh there's probably a monster and I
was like too dumb to realize early on
that it's probably a monster something
some type of creature oh yeah that was
that was really cool trailer though yeah
it's cool I'm excited to play it yeah
and ultimately it comes down and I feel
like they're rebooting in a way where
you don't have to play all them no you
could jump in here and it looks like
they're getting enough exposition and
plus if you know if you've heard of God
of War you're familiar with Kratos as
pinnacles gods yeah that sounds great to
me there was not much character
development between God of War 1 and God
of War 2 you're not missing bone that's
why I think this one will have character
development yeah as they're channeling
this father side of him this mentor side
and I think that's an appealing side to
me you know what he looks like he looks
like Captain Spaulding from The Devil's
Rejects have you know who that is damn
I'm gonna show you why would you show me
this they look like no yes but no go to
the real region you there click that
notification about that cyber channel on
YouTube that cyber channel on twitch.tv
also part of the tgn squadron over and
youtube.com slash user slash gangs go
follow them their live streams and
whatnot and that cyber guy obvious
social media stuff moving on